[Musique]
David coubi bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle S précaution oratoire comme
d'habitude tu es mon avocat donc je vais
te tutoyer pendant cette interview on te
reçoit aujourd'hui à la suite du
jugement Société Générale versus Jérôme
carviel qu'est-ce que tu peux nous en
dire qu'est-ce qui s'est passé quels
sont les résultats
explique-nous écoute c'est c'est assez
simple ça n'est pas l'histoire qu'on
nous avait raconté depuis 9 années tu tu
connais Jérôme kviel comme étant ce ce
trader voyou c'était comme ça qu'il
avait été décrit décrit pour pour avoir
été responsable d'une perte dont
personne n'a prouvé qu'elle existait qui
s'élevait à 4,9 milliards d'euros et
maintenant que la justice est passée et
qu'elle est bien passée il est
responsable à
0,02 % de ces 4,9 milliards d'euros
d'après la justice française
donc en face de cela nous avons Société
Générale qui est une honorable banque
qui elle est responsable
arithmétiquement à hauteur de 99
98 % mais à ce stade-là de notre
entretien ce que j'ai envie de te dire
c'est que dans l'esprit des journalistes
et dans l'esprit des politiques Société
générale c'est un monollythe personne ne
se demande qui est derrière Société
générale on te dit carviel d'un côté et
Société Générale de l'autre et tout le
monde semble se satisfaire de ça nous
nous ne nous satisfaisons pas de ça et
on est en train de regarder qui est
derrière Société Générale qui est
derrière Société Générale bien c'est
dirigeant enfin tu vois c'est c'est
assez simple il y a une ligne
hiérarchique il se trouve que toute la
ligne hiérarchique de Jérôme guviel a
été payée et ça c'est acquis au débat
sont des pièces que nous avons dans le
dossier même si qui étent payé de leur
salaire leur leur responsabilit non mais
écoute que des gens soient payés de leur
salaire je trouve ça plutôt sain dans la
société qui est la nôtre en revanche
d'être payé 7 ans de salaire fixe 7
c'està-dire 5 + 2 quand on est licencié
pour insuffisance professionnelle ça
commence à à poser une question qui est
une question philosophique et qui
s'apparente au prix du silence donc tu
as un opérateur qu'on a voulu isoler et
on y reviendra il y a un mobile à cette
volonté de de l'isoler et en tout cas il
y a une une conséquence à ça c'est que
ça a permis à la banque d'obtenir 2,2
milliards d'euros de de d'argent public
donc l'impôt des Français hein en
violation de la jurisprudence du Conseil
d'État qui était alors en vigueur et
notamment un arrêt pour les pour les des
spécialistes parce que c'est un dossier
où il y a beaucoup de spécialistes donc
les spécialistes qui nous regardent un
arrêt Alcatel CIT du 5 octobre 2007 qui
pose des conditions qui en l'espèce
c'est-à-dire au cas qui nous occupe
n'étit pas rempli ne permettant ainsi
pas à Société Générale de percevoir cet
argent donc on a là ce que ce que je je
je vois comme étant un
mobile pour que Société Générale
perçoive cet argent et ça s'apparente à
un siphonage j'ai eu l'occasion en 2012
de de de dire déjà que que cela me
faisait penser au plus grand cas du
siècle donc
euh de cette affaire qui était une
affaire quasiment un fait divers même si
c'était un fait divers planétaire on
passe à une affaire indéiablement
d'état le ministre des Finances est-ce
que tu as tu as eu des contacts avec lui
est-ce que tu as été contacté par Bery
est-ce que des
associations de la société civile t'ont
demandé un petit peu si la Société
Générale allait pouvoir rembourser ou
est-ce que la Société générale doit doit
ne doit pas est-ce que la Société
Générale a suffisamment de fonds propres
pour pouvoir rembourser alors le
ministre Michel Sapin parce qu'il faut
nommer les gens je on a déjà eu cette
conversation moi ici on est sur sview il
faut donner des noms ben oui c'est ça
parce que si si tu nommes pas ça devient
l'institution et l'institution c'est
personne c'est comme Société Générale
Société générale c'est personne c'est
tout le monde et c'est personne donc le
ministre Michel Sapin à la disposition
duquel nous avons indiqué nous tenir n'a
pas jugé opportun ni de nous recevoir
ni de de de d'adresser
quelques quelques messages en notre
direction que ce soit ni lui alors on
s'attend pasce qu'un ministre appelle
faut pas déconner non plus mais ni lui
ni quiconque de son administration ça
c'est pour répondre à ta première
question les fonds propres de société
général c'est pas mon sujet euh je je
suis pas l'avocat de Société Générale on
sait simplement que leurs comptes sont
faux on sait parce que leur avocat l'a
dit à l'audience il a lâché ça de
manière exaspérée en disant les comptes
de Société Générale sont faux cétait
d'ironie peut-être non non non non non
non non c'était c'était tout à fait
juste sa théorie c'est que euh Jérôme
kviel ayant fait des manœuvres
frauduleuses a condu Société Générale à
présenter au marché des compes faux donc
ça dans la vraie vie c'est-à-dire la vie
où il y a un droit applicable euh c'est
répréhensible mais pas pour Société
Générale hein parce que quand c'est
Société générale c'est c'est pas grave
donc je te redis les fonds propres de la
banque c'est pas notre sujet et est-ce
que Société générale doit ou ne doit pas
bien sûr qu'elle le doit bien sûr
qu'elle doit cet argent puisqu'elle
n'aurait jamais
juridiquement le percevoir alors comment
ça se fait qu'ils sont toujours pas
remboursés mais c'est à l'étude on te on
est on est en train de t'indiquer du
côté de Bery
que les services de l'État te dit Michel
Sapin tu noteras que quand Michel Sapin
parle de l'État il se montre comme ça
lui-même les services de l'État sont en
train de de de de regarder
euh mais Michel Sapin oublie quelque
chose c'est que sous l'empire de son
prédécesseur Pierre Moscovici en 2012
nous avons d'ors et déjà des traces au
dossier pénal traces au terme
desquels la dvni qui est une division
spéciale de de des impôts de Bery était
déjà en train de s'interroger sur le
caractère déductible ou non déductible
de la perte qu'il était coutume alors
d'appeler perte kervielle gageons que si
cette étude nous avait été défavorable
si cette enquête nous avait été
défavorable elle serait sortie
publiquement mais de toute façon les
choses sont claires il y a une
jurisprudence
du Conseil d'État il n'y a rien
au-dessus du Conseil d'État dans l'ordre
judiciaire administratif et en
application de cette
jurisprudence il ne devait pas percevoir
cet argent depuis lors le droit a encore
avancé en mars 2014 puisque la Cour de
cassation a décidé de revenir sur la
répartition entre Jérôme Kerviel et
Société Générale de ces 4000ard9
renvoyant à la cour d'appel de
Versailles tu m'avais reçu d'ailleurs
peu avant le mois de juin alors que nous
pl là-bas et maintenant nous avons une
un résultat qui est définitif qui laisse
1 million d'euros à la charge de Jérôme
Kerviel et 4,9 milliards moin 1 million
à la charge de Société Générale c'est ça
ce calcul 0,02 % de responsabilité pour
Jérôme kviel et
99,98 % pour Société Générale donc là le
débat
semble clos si on regarde les choses en
légaliste mais c'est pas comme ça que
c'est regardé quand quand on a entendu
parler de la condamnation à 1 million
d'euros euh elle a été formulée de telle
façon par le la la justice comme une une
peine à hauteur d'homme
ouais qu'est-ce que tu en
penses
euh écoute
euh qu'est-ce que j'en
pense j'en pense que tout ce qui fait
que l'opinion la presse un certain
nombre de d'activistes de nos amis je ne
t'ai pas répondu sur les associations
tout à l'heure de contribuable donc la
réponse pour le l'expurger est oui nous
sommes en contact avec des associations
qui manie parfaitement bien le le le
corpus juridique fiscal et qui ont
compris qu'il convenait de recouvrer
donc notre travail et de et d'avancer
avec eux et de voir comment on peut
permettre à la collectivité nationale de
récupérer l'argent qui qui qui lui
revient surtout en ce moment oui puisque
il paraît qu'on est serré il paraît
qu'on est dans une crise économique hein
tu tu connais toute cette théorie de
c'est c'est la crise économique donc
tenez-vous tranquille c'est la crise
à la réalité on n'est pas en crise
économique mais ça c'est autre chose
bon pour revenir à ta question j'en
pense que je j'ai l'honneur de défendre
un citoyen français Jérôme kviel qui est
condamné à un million d'euros alors que
ça fait 9 ans qu'il vit avec au-dessus
de la tête une somme faramineuse de près
de 5 milliards qu' a pour la peine n'est
pas à hauteur d'homme et qu'il est
condamné dans
un dispositif où tous les opérateurs
les chevises ouvrières de ce dossier je
pense à l'officier de police judiciaire
Nathalie Leroi qu'on avait déjà eu
l'occasion d'évoquer et à la procureure
Chantal de leris qui est toutes deux en
charge du dossier disent ensemble que le
dossier a été
truqué avec des complicités au sein du
parquet de Paris c'est grave c'estve
comme accusation moi je le je je le sais
mais c'est c'est pas une
accusation c'est un fait c'estàd d que
ces gens-là nous disent des choses vous
avez des preuves et c'est un point de
confort mais bien sûr quelle preuve
évidemment mais les témoignages de ces
personnesl d'accord qui sont à soi seul
des preuves et et et quand quand nous on
vous disait ça à l'époque vous pouviez
vous dire oui bon benah l'avocat de
kerverviel est en train de turbuler il
est en train de faire je sais pas quoi
de la presse ou ou il fait malin ou
théâtre oui oui ou de la politique ou
duf tu vois on nous a collé tout un tas
de de de machin mais maintenant c'est
plus nous qui le disons c'est les gens
qui ont fourni le travail de base ayant
permis à la condamnation de Jérôme
gerviel donc ça devient un autre dossier
et dans ce contexte là on a vécu en juin
une audience un peu particulière où il y
avait les avocats de Société Générale
que j'avais fait citer à comparaître une
personnâ eux personnellement puisqu'ils
sont mentionnés dans les fameux
enregistrements de la policière sur la
procureur de la République
enregistrement dixite frauduleux ou sans
lacordse c'est
ça d'après ce qu' nous est présenté sans
l'accord de l'un des intéressés mais ça
demeure une information c'està dire que
tu pour le pénal c'est recevable ce type
d'enregistrement oui complètement on a
une jurisprudence bê en cour sur le
sujet et si tu veux on doit arbitrer
entre une éventuelle violation de la vie
privée d'un côté et le mandat qui m'est
donné en tant
qu'avocat d'avoir à faire mon travail
donc je je j'ai opté pour l'option qui
me semblait la plus saine
c'est-à-dire faire mon travail donc moi
je on me remet un élément dans ma main
là ici au terme duquel le procès est
truqué et je dois en tant qu'omme en
tant qu'avocat décider si j'utilise cet
élément ou si j'écrase le coup en T etes
conscience oui mais il y a pas il y a
pas de
match tu fais le travail voilà donc dans
ce contexte là cette audience un peu
particulière où il y avait les avocats
de Société Générale mise en cause
personnellement le parquet qui est parti
qui est une une des parties au procès
pénal et la juridiction où on fait jouer
des enregistrements pendant cette
audience indiquant que le parquet euh
c'est compromis dans le traitement
judiciaire de ce dossier alors
évidemment ça ça fait des tâches sur les
murs tu vois parce qu'il faut pas dire
ça
normalement ce qui est attendu de nous
tous c'est que l'un d'entre vous vous
justiciable moi je suis un justiciable
aussi mais l'un d'entre vous euh est
dans cette situation et bien euh on doit
euh laisser filer bon c'est pas comme ça
que que les avocats de mon cabinet
moi-même l'avons entendu et donc on a
décidé de de d'amener ce débat jusqu'au
bout avec une particularité que je
trouve absolument fascinante c'est que
personne à
date ne s'est inquiété de savoir ce
qu'il y avait dans ces enregistrements
au-delà des des quelques passages que
que j'ai pris la décision stratégique de
révéler personne ne nous demande C
enregistrement pr la presse n'a pas
bougé le Canar en m personne personne
miaap part a fait des articles euh la
presse a fait des articles ENF la presse
ça veut rien dire tu sais bien mais
certains médias ont fait des articles
mais moi je ne te parle pas de presse je
te parle d'une exploitation euh par la
justice ou ouis c'estàd que si je viens
chez toi en te disant ton machin est
truqué euh bah tu as soit intérêt à
couvrir tes troupes soit intérêt à dire
ah bon bah montre-moi les éléments et je
vais statuer et donc là que ce soit le
doyen des juges d'instruction qui est en
charge d'un certain nombre de dossiers
Roger Leloire que ce soit le parquet de
Paris j'ai personnellement avisé
François Molins de l'existence de ces
enregistrements que ce soit le bâtonnier
de Paris puisque il s'agit de de de
d'avocat donc pas complètement inepte
que que que que l'un de ces trois corps
se saisit du sujet que ce soit les
magistrats du siège on décide de ne pas
regarder se disant que
euh ça va nous passer tu vois et on va
on va puisqu'on nous demande pas on
devrait euh peut-être penser à autre
chose au bout d'un moment ou oublier que
nous avons ça c'est
absurde j'ai vu que le dossier était en
train d'être déporté à Lille raconte-moi
raconte-moi un peu un peu cette
déportation à
Lille
alors c'est pas le dossier principal qui
est qui est dépaysé à Lille c'est le le
dossier qui qui se met à exister par une
plainte de la fameuse procureur de la
République Chantal de leris contre le
commandant de police Nathalie Leroi
qu'elle rencontre avec laquelle elle
parle librement donc on entend ce
qu'elle dit quand elle parle librement
et c'est très intéressant de l'entendre
et à la réalité nous avons
exploité 12 ou 13 petits extraits sur 35
minutes d'enregistrement
utile donc à ceux qui te regarderaient
et notamment mes adversaires et qui sont
en train de se demander si on a mis la
gomme sur les premiers éléments ou si on
a attendu décidant de garder le meilleur
pour plus tard bien je je je les laisse
comme il est dit dans la chute de Camu
coucher avec le mystère euh je pense que
tu as la réponse à la question que je
pose et quex aussi hein je dis ça
ironiquement mais cette procureur a pris
la décision de déposer plainte contre
Nathalie Leroi pour commandant Nathalie
Leroi pour violation de la vie privée et
a priori mais nous ne savons pas où est
cette plainte aujourd'hui et et personne
n'a jugé opportun même en terme de
confraternité de nous l'adresser contre
Jérôme carviel et contre moi-même en
qualité de
receleur et finalement l'ironie du sujet
et et et et je trouve ça assez
incroyable mais mais pourquoi pas c'est
que la façon dont ce sujet va
rentrer dans le système judiciaire se
produit au travers d'une plainte dirigée
contre
nous c'estàdire que les gens qui sont en
train de se débattre en disant ça fait 9
ans qu'on vous dit qu'un dossier est
truqué voilà les éléments dont nous
disposons et bien la justice va se
saisir de ces élémentsl au travers d'une
plainte qui est dirigée et déposée
contre nous alors euh moi j'ai à
remercier nos adversaires de nous offrir
ce théâtre d'opération puisque comme je
te le disais auparavant sans cela la
justice ne s'en saisissait pas donc on
va attendre sereinement et
tranquillement de pouvoir aller discuter
du fond parce que la forme c'est très
important hein on l'a vu encore cette
semaine avec le l'intervention de de
Jérôme Kerviel et peut-être
m'interrogerais-tu là-dessus à un moment
ou un autre en face de de d'alin Jupé
donc le le tu vois les internautes les
réseaux sociaux se sont fait les échos
de cette de cette forme en disant mais
comment ça et cetera mais le fond ça
n'intéresse jamais personne tu parles de
Jupé Jupé ou les autres politiques
qu'est-ce qu'ils en disent qu'est-ce
qu'ils en pensent quelles sont leurs
connaissan quelle est la connaissance du
dossier euh est-ce qu' ils ont la
moindre idée comment fonctionnent les
choses ou ils sont on va dire avec un
regard dedans dit alors c'est c'est
compliqué de te répondre d'une manière
de façon générale parce qu'il existe des
politiques qui ont très largement
contribué à à à enlever le le le dossier
de l'ornière dans dans laquelle le
sénateur communiste Éric boet Jean-Luc
Mélenchon eva jolie Julien Baillou
Europe Écologie Les Verts le député
républicain George Fennec ancien
magistrat coauteur de la ré forme avec
le député socialiste anain Touré sur le
la révision pénale Erik laosé Marinol
linman Ops Jérôme Gede l'ancien Ministre
Benoît Apparu Édouard Philippe soutien
de de de d'un Jupé François bairou un
temps tu vois donc il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont Nicolas dupontaignnan qu'on
est parti remercier à son congrès ça
aussi ça a été oh là là mon Dieu tu vois
ces gens-là ont contribué à à déplanter
le dossier mais ces gens-là ne sont pas
au pouvoir
et et ce qui m'intéresse c'est de voir
l'espèce d'inertie qui existe au pouvoir
et qu'on qu'on parle d'une présidence
Sarkozy ouune présidence Hollande et
puis on a compris euh dans ce dans ce ce
ce cet échange Jérôme kviel Alain Jupé
que si Alain jupet devait être président
de la République ça ne serait pas euh
son sujet de de de de prédilection euh
puisque ce n'est pas avec une langue en
bois qu'on décrit le mieux euh les
problématiques du pays c'est en nomant
les choses et en apportant des solutions
et c'est pas ça c'est pas ce à quoi nous
avons assisté lors de lors de ce débat
lors de cet échange assist à quoi j'ai
assisté à à un Jérôme
kervviel à bout de de de de souffle
parce que parce que parce que 9 années
de combat laisse des traces et et la vie
qui va avec est une vie qui est
compliquée pour lui incidemment pour moi
pour d'autres
euh et ce Jérôme kviel
là disait de son mieux à Alain
Jupé la façon dont il voyait les choses
euh et Alain Jupé répondait
avec une espèce de Satis satisfaction
affichée sur ce que on a fait disait-il
alors que je je n'ai pas compris qu'il
gouvernait entre entre 2008 et et et
aujourd'hui 2016 mais sur ce qu'on a
fait euh
disait-il euh il était premier ministre
avant hein pas pas pendant ces années-là
euh pour réguler le système bancaire et
nous nous considérons avec d'autres avec
avec les gens de de d'attaque avec un
certain nombre de de personnes très
impliquées dans des milieux associatifs
et ou activistes et tu sais que je n'ai
aucune difficulté pour discuter avec ces
hommes politiques mainstream ou euh pour
aller me perdre euh auprès d'autres
d'autres soutiens et d'autres d'autres
personnes qui peuvent apporter à la
cause que je sers euh et il disait que
grosso modo on a fait beaucoup de choses
depuis la la crise de 2008 et puis
s'agissant du reste il a une vision très
légaliste des choses quand il s'agit de
ne pas condamner
euh la façon dont le système bancaire
est dévoyé tu as parlé de la séparation
des banques d'affaires et des banques de
détail non c'était pas le sujet c'était
pas le sujet
pendant ce pendant ce débat mais on on
voit quelle est la la position et on
voit surtout que rien ne ressemble plus
à un ancien inspecteur des finances
qu'un autre inspecteur des
finances un sujet de club ici tu
comprends un sujet de club ça aussi ça
va être beaucoup critiqué parce que il
ne faut pas dire dans ce dossier qu'il y
a un pacte de place ça les insulte c'est
interdit c'est tabou
euh les gens comme toi et moi on est
insultés quand on est insulté eux je ne
parle pas d'in Jupé je parle de de de de
cette caste dirigeante ils sont insultés
alors qu'ils sont décrits décrit comme
ils
sont tu vois il existe des clubs
aujourd'hui
où tu n'entres pas je n'entre pas kviel
n'entre pas
euh les petits contribuables n'entrent
pas et où un certain nombre de décisions
sont prises et discutéé
oui on arrive aux élections présidentiel
est-ce que tu es pour ou contre le fait
que ce se voulant accéder se voulant
prétendre à la plus haute fonction de
l'état est un casier judiciaire vierge
oui tu connais ma
position sur le sur le sujet je ne je ne
conçois pas un instant qu'il puisse en
être autrement je ne conçois pas qu'on
ait pu avoir quoi que ce soit à faire
avec des donniers publics quoi que ce
soit à faire d'illégal avec des donniers
public sans que cela laisse des des
traces qui soient durables et
coercitives et et d'une manière générale
nous réfléchissions avec un certain
nombre d'amis aux conditions qui pourrai
permettre à un con comme moi de revoter
par exemple puisque tu sais que je ne je
ne vote pas je n'ai jamais voté et en
fait moi ce qu'il me faudrait euh là sur
notre table dans notre table commune sur
notre table nationale ça serait une une
un dispositif légal donc une loi et nous
entendons interroger les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle sur ce sujet
une loi prévoyant que lorsqu'un élu de
la République un
fonctionnaire est pris la main dans le
sac en train de détourner des fonds
publics on veut un qu'il soit inéligible
à vie alors je connais les petits verrou
juridiques qu'il faudra faire sauter
pour obtenir ça il y aura un débat
d'experts
ce qu' chaque notion il y a ses experts
ça c'est très intéressant euh inéligible
à vie et que la collectivité nationale
leur prennent tout alors tout on te dira
que j'ai une vision très radicale du
sujet et je j'assume cette vision
radicale mais si on veut quelque chose
d'un peu plus édulcoré parce que tu sais
on est en 2016 donc il faut que les
choses soient un peu doucereuse comme ça
et lissée voilà sans faire trop de vague
on peut envisager que la somme qui sera
prise par la collectivité nationale à à
à ce genre d'élu euh qui se seront
dévoyés sera la somme la plus élevée
entre ce qu'ils ont perçu depuis le
début de leur carrière politique en
terme de salaire euh traitement et
défraimement et ou la somme qu'ils ont
euh détourné pour toi et ça ça
permettrait de revoter tu vois
c'est-à-dire que quand on parle de la
restauration de la confiance dans la vie
politique euh il faut pas que ça soit de
la de la parlotte il faut pas que ce
soit des mots faut que ce soit ferme ben
oui parce que tu ne peux pas expliquer
que euh tu ne peux pas expliquer à nos
concitoyens tout à la fois que une loi
est fabriquée qu'elle est
dure qu'elle est inévitable qu'elle
s'applique en toutes circonstances sauf
quand il s'agit de ministre la fameuse
justice à deux vitesses la justice
entrepte bah oui écoute je
je je je ne vois pas beaucoup d'anciens
ministres en prison en garde à vue ou
en en voit beaucoup prétendre à la
fonction présidentielle non ce qu' on
été condam anné avec beaucoup d'affaires
de
détournement de fraude à
l'élection financement des campagnes
hier sur les réseaux sociaux tu as tu as
un ancien procureur qui s'appelle
Philippe
Bilger qui a une chaîne Youtube je crois
bien
ok qui qui qui criait au scandale tu
sais c'est quand on crie au scandale par
tweet tu vois ce que je veux dire qui
criait au scandale en 140 signes en
s'interrogeant sur les conditions dans
lesquelles on pouvait être en face
d'Alain Jupé quand on était condamné
pénalement euh et réciproquement bah je
je enfin moi moi je suis pas là pour
euh raviver des des des des mauvais
souvenirs chez tel ou tel mais mais si
on va sur le sujet des condamnations
pénales sur un sujet carviel Jupé euh
enfin sauf à penser qu'il y a des des
des condamnations qui sont euh signifi
que d'autres ou plus légère que d'autres
tu vois
mais j'avais l'impression que tu vois il
y avait des des espèces de trompettes de
l'orchestre là qui nous qui nous
chantait une une musique qu'on connaît
déjà très bien et qu'on sait aujourd'hui
décrypter alors en 2012 Quand quand je
prenais la la tête de la défense pénale
de Jérôme kviel tout ça pouvait un peu
me me m'étonner me questionner
m'interroger tu vois je pouvais me dire
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe mais là on
est en 2016 mon client est responsable
de 0,02 % de la de Société Générale et
en dépit de cette responsabilité
infinitésimale Société Générale est
parvenu à siphonner 2,2 milliards
d'euros d'argent public alors si on a
postulé qu'on était en crise nous les
français on veut ce fric et je te le dis
comme ça on veut ce fric maintenant bah
oui maintenant pourquoi plus tard il y a
des intérêts sur tout ça enfin tu vois
alors on te dit on commandite des
rapports des enquêtes des trucs des
machins quand tu entends un politique te
dire qu'il va faire un une enquête
monter une commission ou ou un machin
comme ça ça ça veut dire que en
définitive et tu le sais très bien il ne
fera rien donc on on doit muscler notre
attention pour pour pour faire bien
attention à ce que cet argent revienne
dans la collectivité nationale parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre issu légal
possible ou alors qu'on nous dise bon
ben quand c'est la banque les
gars c'est pas pareil dans ce cas-là si
si si nos concitoyens sont d'accord et
je pas j'ai pas de difficulté j'aimerais
ouvrir une parenthèse et discuter avec
toi euh de l'État du
monde comment tu perçois je vais te
citer des des mots des des sujets comme
ça tu tu choisiras de temps coufré dans
dans celui que tu veux l'élection
américaine Trump Clinton la Syrie les
tensions avec la Russie Bachar elAssad
les frappes nucléaires préventives
américaines les tensions avec
l'OTAN la déstabilisation de la ceinture
méditerranéenne les flux de migrants les
flux alors écoute tu sais je je je suis
toujours mal à l'aise pour pour
discourir sur des sujets qui ne sont pas
expert qui ne sont pas oui parce que je
je je me fous assez de la gueule euh des
des experts autoproclamés euh euh qui
qui publient euh parle avec ton cœur en
tant citoyen un bouquin tu vois aux
éditions de La pignle quand quand ça les
intéresse de le faire donc je je n'ai
pas envie de de de de verser dans ce
dans ce défaut là mais le point commun
que je vois avec tout ce que tu viens de
que je vois dans tout ce que tu viens
citer ce point commun c'est
systématiquement la manière dont
euh le pouvoir et l'argent sont traités
et et commentil
s'imbrique on a quand même à peu près
tous compris que la crise des migrants
qui est un drame humanitaire auquel il
m'est difficile de d'être insensible et
je n'ai pas la volonté de d'y être
insensible mais pour autant je n'ai pas
de solution et donc je je te le dis très
clairement mais on a tous à peu près
bien compris que la déstabilisation au
plan géopolitique de ce qui s'est passé
dans ces zones du monde était la cause
de ce qui est en train de passer de de
ce que de ce qui est en train de se
passer et je je garde notamment à
l'esprit un discours de de Kaddafi alors
je je te dis pas que je je regarde en
boucle le discours de Kaddafi mais je me
souviens qu'il disait si je tombe vous
serez dans cette situation où des gens
déferleront sur vos
côtes je ne peux pas m'empêcher de voir
que c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer les raisons pour lesquelles on
est parti en Irak pour lesquell avant ça
on était en Afghanistan pour lesquels on
est parti en Syrie pour lesquels on a on
a on a fait ce qui ce qui s'est passé tu
as prend systématiquement 10 ans après
qu'il n'y a pas d'armes de destruction
massive que tu vois donc que la Libye
c'était pour des raisons personnelles et
des choses comme ça je sais pas si tu as
vu le le c'est un papier d'un canard
anglais très connu qui disait que
Sarkozi était parti en Libye pour régler
des des affaires personnelles j'ai j'ai
pas j'ai pas à prendre position
là-dessus je je je connais je lis parce
que je je suis très assidu tu vois en
terme de consommation de d'information
mais je je suis pas impliqué en tant
qu'avocat dans dans ces dossiers donc
j'ai pas envie de verser dans le j'ai là
on veut l'homme on veut l'homme le bah
je trouve que tout ça devrait se
regarder et que à partir du moment
où la presse ou la justice prétend que
que que que ces raisons sont au centre
des décisions qui ont été prises et qui
nous étaient présenté comme étant des
décisions quasiment humain itire je
pense que la justice devrait inscrire au
R de ses priorités de de de nous dire et
peut-être avant mai 2017 si c'est le cas
ou si c'est et c'est c'est peut-être ça
j'en sais rien si c'est une campagne de
déstabilisation de l'ancien président de
la République Nicolas Sarkozi tu vois et
moi je n'ai pas d'idée parce que je nai
pas d'éléments et quand j'ai pas
d'élément je ne prends pas position
est-ce que tu connais le budget de
fonctionnement du ministère de la
Justice
français je crois sans me tromper qu'il
est de 2 milliards et le budget de
fonctionnement du ministère de
l'écologie non pas d'idée alors d'après
mes souvenirs et je demanderai aux
internautes de vérifier le budget de la
justice en France est inférieur à celui
de
l'écologie je je crois pas qu'il faille
comparer les deux tu vois parce que que
que le budget de l'écologie soit plus
élevé que celui de la justice si celui
de la justice n'est pas ridiculement bas
je je trouve ça enfin tu vois l'écologie
en tant que
telle si si on ne comprend pas
aujourd'hui qu'on est en train de de mal
se comporter par rapport à notre éc
système il me semble qu'on loupe quelque
chose tu vois sur la gestion de l'eau
sur le le le le il il y a d'autres
sujets dont on a beaucoup parlé sur le
le tu vois l'élevage en batterie des
animaux sur la manière dont ils sont
abattus sur bon ça c'est c'est pas c'est
pas un monde et là tu m'interroges pas
en tant qu'avocat ça c'est pas c'est pas
un monde qui me qui me convient et dans
lequel je je je vis sereinement raison
pour laquelle je ne Bee plus de viande
depuis qu sont ou d'ailleurs quelles
sont teses tes mesures personnel de tous
les jours pour essayer que le monde
aille mieux tu manges plus de viande
j'essaie de faire mon
job non c'est pas pour que le monde
aille mieux c'est c'est c'est l'idée que
tu te fais
de de ta participation dans ce grand
tout moi j'essaie de ne pas participer
au au tu vois des schémas qui me
semblent inacceptables lesquels bah ça
je prenais pour exemple par exemple le
fait de ne pas bouffer de viande je n'ai
pas envie de participer à ça j'avais lu
et je sais pas si c'est le cas ou pas tu
vois je parce que je suis pas
spécialiste de cette matière qu'il faut
6000 l d'eau pour fabriquer 1 kg de
bœuf je peux pas m'empêcher de
rapprocher ça euh euh de de de des
conséquences de la sécheresse dans des
continents qui ne sont pas les nôtres et
et je ne peux pas m'empêcher de de de me
souvenir que sur ces continents là dans
ces continents là il y a des il y a des
gens qui meurent quand tu as pas d'au tu
ne cultives pas quand tu cultives pas tu
es obligé de chercher à bouffer tous les
jours et quand tu es obligé de faire ça
tu tu ne peux pas t'éduquer donc il me
semble qu'il y a quand même une volonté
là de de de garder des clivages nord-
sudud de garder des et et ensuite il
faudra pas trop s'étonner si euh si ces
gens-là ont envie d'avoir une vie
meilleure c'est je je trouve pas ça
absurde c'est quoi ta plus grosse
peur alors moi tu sais j'ai pas trop je
j'ai pas trop de je je mets pas souvent
la trouille dans dans dans mes équations
de vie mais
euh mais grosso modo ça serait de se de
se mettre à à ressembler à ce que nous
combattons ça ça me plairait
pas tu vois on est encore dans des âges
où on peut se dire c'est des jeunes cons
idéalistes quelle est ta plus grosse
joie faire mon job cette décision à 0,02
% tu vois c'est une vraie
joie alors je je j'ai lu quelques
pisttiède qui disait ah bah oui mais
quand même carviel un million d'euros il
dit qu'il est satisfait et cetera et
mais quand tu viens de 5 milliards
d'euros de
condamnation tu vois ce que je veux dire
et si Société Générale envie de
recouvrer ce million d'euros
euh on l'invite même à le faire on en a
presque besoin pour la suite parce
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui dans une
équation et on partage cette équation
avec eux ou plus ils taperont et plus
ils
perdront donc ça tu vois c'est une vraie
joie je te parle pas du recouvrement je
te parle de de de se dire
que je je j'interviens au sein d'un
cabinet le cabinet 28 octobre qui est un
cabinet
de de de gens courageux et qui ont fait
leur travail honnêtement sans
s'arrêter j'aime j'aime beaucoup
cette cette cette idée si on te
proposait d'être ministre de la Justice
un jour
tuaccepterais c'est complètement
fictionnelle ta question Sky fictionnel
mais est-ce que tu accepterais je je
crois pas
pardon je crois pas ça dépendra
j'imagine de de quiil proposera et de et
de quelle sera la
l'attitude mais tu vois je je crois pas
qu'un ministre puisse tout à la foi euh
s'occuper tu sais un ministre c'est
comme toi et moi dans la vraie vie
c'est-à-dire que c'est quelqu'un qui qui
doit dormir quelques heures qui doit se
doucher qui qui doit manger qui qui peut
avoir une vie de famille qui qui fait ce
qu'il a à faire dans sa vie tu vois et
je pense pas qu'on puisse s'occuper de
la conduite pénale par exemple des
affaires du pays
et être en charge également des des
dossiers judiciaires des des anciens
ministres des grands patrons des de tout
ce qui s'appelle ces dossiers signalés
là cette espèce d'écume qui fait que je
pense que c'est un pleintemp pour eux de
de les gérer donc être ministre de la
Justice de la de la justice sans gérer
les machins entre copains oui c'est
c'est c'est si ce ministère là existait
mais je te le dis tout de go il n'existe
pas je trouveraai je trouverais
intéressant de de de de regarder ça mais
moi je ne vois pas
euh tu vois qui me le demanderait et et
pour quelle raison j'accepterai par
ailleurs et qui tu verrais à la place de
notre ministre de la
Justice je je j'ai pas d'idée dans cette
organisation institutionnelle je n'ai
pas de je n'ai pas d'idée on sait que le
Président de la République est le
premier magistrat de France et on sait
que les deux derniers n'ont pas rempli
ce rôle- làà c'est tu vois alors chef
des armées quand c'est les arrangés ça
ils aiment bien le faire euh mais je je
n'ai pas de je n'ai je je n'ai pas vu
passer de de mesures qui qui permettent
de de de s'occuper de la de la politique
pénal ou pénitentiaire du du pays quand
tu vois nos chiffres sur les prisons
quand tu vois l'état des prisons et je
suis un avocat donc il m'arrive de de
d'aller en prison tu tu tu dois faire un
effort intellectuel pour te rappeler
qu'on est en France c'est vraiment le
tir monde mais c'est c'est mais enfin il
y a tout un tas de rapport qui qui sont
publques mais bien sûr qu'on l'a été
nous n'avons de cess que que que de
l'êre il y a une plainte qui est déposée
là parce qu'il y a des nuisibles dans
les prisons
il alors on se dit ensuite
que la
prison tu vois on a envie de vendre au
au à la population française la la
prison comme la prison pardon comme
étant un un moyen de
réinsertion euh c'est c'est une mesure
répressive mais on n'est pas censé
sortir de prison plus délinquant qu'on y
est entré
ou plus radicalisé c'est un autre sujet
mais mais il est il est cousin du du
sujet que j'évoque effectivement et là
en l'occurrence on voit mal comment on
pourrait sortir de prison dans les
conditions qui sont les conditions de
détention actuelles en France
euh plus réinséré ou moins délinquant
que ce qu'on y est entré le fait que
Manuel Vals souhaite construire une
trentaine de de prisons en plus et que
les pays nordiques eux
enferment quelle est ta conclusion
là-dessus si cette mesure émerge dans
les 6 derniers mois de mandat j'ai pas
grand chose à t'en dire en fait
dur non mais enfin tu vois ce sont des
gens qui sont là depuis depuis 2012 au
pouvoir il il sculpte de la fumée encore
il brass de l'air chaud je je je sais
pas il y a des il y a des intérêts qui
me
qui me dépasse moi je ne vois les choses
tu vois que que qu'en ma qualité de euh
d'avocat dans les dossiers qui qui sont
les miens dieu merci pas seulement
dossier Société Générale et et et je je
mesure les décalages entre la théorie et
la
pratique trop souvent et et donc c
espèce d'annonce politique en fin de
mandat
je je sais pas Trump ou Clinton je ni
l'un ni l'autre la peste ou le coléra
oui écoute je je sais pas tout ça me
j'ai toujours été fasciné par cette
capacité qu'avaient nos sociétés à
fabriquer des familles de dirigeants on
a ça chez les Kennedy mais Kennedy c'est
tu vois c'est c'est des films couleur
donc c'est c'est ça a quelque chose d'un
peu exotique d'un peu vintage c'est pas
mal tu vois ils avaient de la gueule
mais mais quand tu mets au prisme de ce
que je suis en train de te dire la
famille Hollande royale qu'est-ce qu'on
est en train de nous dire que deux
personnes de la même promo de
l'enat même promo euh qui partagent leur
vie qui sont dans le même courant
politique peuvent être candidats en 2007
et emporter l'élection en 2012 on a eu
ça avec Bush et Bush aux États-Unis et
maintenant Clinton Bill Clinton et
Hillary Clinton euh enfin tu vois ça ça
ça me semble être une sorte de d'OPA
agressive sur l'intérêt public j'ai du
mal à croire qu'à chaque fois les plus
compétences soient dans la même famille
ça me ça m'émerveille un peu ça on les
politiques qu'on mérite ah oui largement
ou oui largement ça pour ça c'est c'est
très bien la la démocratie est parfaite
pour
ça quelle solution à
ça tu sais on en a déjà on en a déjà
beaucoup parlé moi je pense que ça passe
par la justice et je pense que sans
justice indépendante il y a pas de
démocratie j'ai eu déjà souvent
l'occasion
de de le de le dire d'en parler de le
développer
mais c'est c'est un pilier
euh qui est qui est indépassable et
aujourd'hui la justice n'est pas
indépendante il faut que les gens qui
nous regardent le le sache le mesure
s'en inquiète et se dis surtout que ça
peut leur tomber dessus c'est terrifiant
de se dire que tu peux être pris dans
une une une mâchoire judiciaire alors
bon quand tu y es pour quelque
chose tu connais la loi tu la violes tu
te fais attraper tu es puni tuassume ça
c'est un
sujet mais mais quand on te met en
travers pour des raisons qui te
dépassent c'est hautement destructeur en
terme de de vie qu'est-ce que tu penses
du un autre sujet qu'est-ce que tu
penses du du cas du général Picmal qui
s'est fait radier du cadre des armées
pour avoir appelé à manifester je je je
ne souhaite pas prendre position sur sur
ces sujets que je connais trop
peu quand quand en France si tu devais
voter aux prochaines élections
présidentielles
ouais tu voterais pour qui qui qui m'y
forcerait moi comment tu ferais c'est
compliqué je te prends sur un ring et je
t'éclate euh non
[Musique]
écoute je je je ne sais pas te répondre
tu soutiendrais
personne si je je serais en mesure de
soutenir des gens euh
que j'estime être de d'honnête personne
mais pas dans le système institutionnel
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui parce que
parce que je je ne pense pas qu'ils
seront en capacité de de faire ce
pourquoi ils sont là on les aura mis là
enfin vous les aurez mis là
euh donc je je qu'est-ce que tu penses
des Civic tech qu'est-ce que c'est les
nouvelles plateformes pour que la
démocra s'exprime grâce au pouvoir
numérique bah je je on est en train de
de de regarder un projet comme ça avec
des clients de de mon
cabinet mais ils le disent en français
donc c'est pour ça que je savais pas ce
que c'éit comment ils le disent bah
despl des plateformes participatives
comme tu l'as dit quand tu quand tu as
arrêté de Framer et que tu et que tu
m'as dit les choses normalement en fait
euh alors je ne frime pas c'est le thème
du colloc de ce weekend avec Axel le
maire sur les Civic tech c'est très bien
si si même Axel Lemer se met à on lui
passe le bonjour d'ailleurs très bien
euh bah je je ça fait quelques années
que je suis assez émerveillé par la
capacité que qu'on a à nous faire
voter s'agissant de de tout un tas de
trucs dont on dont on a rigoureusement
rien à [__] je te parle de programme
télé en tapant un ou deux au 36 machin
là sur nos portables et où on a toujours
pas trouvé de moyen de créer une
application
numérique permettant de faire des des
votations comme les Suisses le font je
dis pas qu'ils le font avec des
applications numérique mais on pourrait
envisager d'avoir une application sur no
nos trop nombreuses tablettes qui
peuplent nos nos foyers nos bureaux nos
truc no machin pour dire
bah on arrête de vous donner à vous
politique des blancins qui durent 5
années et et sur les choses qui sont un
peu signifiante on vous consulte et ça
serait pas complètement idiot je pense
que de
développer ce type de de de d'outil tu
vois en ayant une plateforme unique où
voilà le gouvernement va euh consulter
ses
citoyens je pense que nous irons vers
cela est-ce que tu penses que les
citoyens sont suffisamment apte à
prendre leur destin en main bah ça
dépend de la façon dont ils sont formés
c'est tout le c'est tout le travail de
de d'Alexandre Jardin par exemple et de
de BBZ de bleu blanc zèbre sur le le euh
sur l'éducation sur l'éducation au sens
l'éducation nationale Lire et faire lire
enfin toutes ces associations qui sont
des associations absolument
formidables dont l'objet de dont l'objet
est de de de de de travailler sur le le
le degré de conscience de nos
concitoyens sur l'acquisition de leur
vocabulaire
sur parce qu'en fait plus plus tu es con
et plus tu plus tu es facile à rouler et
ça c'est un calcul qui na échappé à
personne je trouve qu'on est de plus en
plus en ce moment je sais pas le
quantifier j'ai pas envie que tu
m'amènes dans l'espèce de de dans les
cordes de c'était mieux avant mais mais
euh je trouve qu'on a essayé et éculé
tout un tas de systèmes qui sont des
systèmes perdants et qu'on est on est
tout le temps en train de de de
d'essayer de les de les sauver de les
perfuser alors qu'il y a des systèmes
qui sont là à nos portes et qu'on qu'on
a suffisamment d'imagination pour
essayer de les bâtir qui pourrait
fonctionner de manière un peu plus
humaine et euh et un peu moins déconante
tu serais prêt à monter une barricade
euh ça dépend des intérêts en jeu mais
oui oui j'ai pas de difficulté oui
est-ce que tu penses qu'on est à la
veille de la nuit du 4 août non je sais
pas je sais pas je sais pas si on peut
le dire comme ça mais je pense que on
est à la veille d'un effondrement et on
avait déjà discuté de ça si ma mémoire
est bonne euh qui sera un effondrement
euh euh civil ou un
effondrement financier ouais
euh une implosion mais tu sais entre
Noël et le jour de l'an dernier en
2015 nos chers politiques ont voté une
loi permettant de de piquer sur les
compes bancaire tout ce qui est des
Français tout ce qui est au-dessus de
100000 € pour sauver des banques qui
sont en faillite
euh de la même manière Michel Sapin
pendant que les journalistes étaient en
vacances a nommé comme dire eur de
cabinet à Bercy son cabinet un monsieur
qui s'appelle Thierry Olagnon qui était
le patron de la banque d'investissement
de Société
Générale quand même un peu il y a un
sujet tu vois parce que le sujet des 2
milliards 2 il est pas nouveau donc je
je n'accuse pas ces gens de de de faire
du conflit d'intérêt je te dis
simplement
que va exister un moment où tout ça va
se
voir et donc là on continuera de de
d'être posé comme des gros culs devant
TF1 en train de regarder je sais pas
quoi bon j'ai pas la télé donc je peux
pas nourrir mon exemple mais où on va
prendre le destin du pays en main quand
je dis on c'est nos concitoyens tu vois
et et on fera des les choses telles
qu'elles doivent être faites et je pense
qu'on verra ça de notre vivant nous
là les gens qui sont dans cette pièce je
pense que c'est notre génération
qui qui fera ce ce chemin ou le subir
bah c'est c'est à nous de décider oui
tu penses que la presse est qui reste
une presse libre en
France ben euh
elle est amusante ta question parce que
euh ma présence ici alors que nous
sommes invités partout Jérôme kervial et
moi est une forme de
réponse me semble-t-il
euh c'est dire que dans un tu vois
trouver un média où tu as de la place où
tu as du temps
euh où tu n'es pas censuré tronqué
travesti alors il y a des il y a des
journaux qui font de l'investigation qui
font ça très bien mais ils n'ont pas ce
genre de format
euh et puis d'une manière générale tu
sais très bien quelle est ma position
sur le
sujet quand tu regardes dans des dans
des canards divers et variés
euh un papier sur l'affaire dit carviel
et que la page d'à côté c'est une
publicité en quadricromis pour la
Société Générale du comprends très bien
que toi tu es un fait divers d'actualité
et que tu n'es pas un annonceur parce
que tu es pas totalement débile donc tu
tu tu comprends très bien qu'il y en a
un qui n'a pas payé c'est toi et qu'il y
en a un qui a payé c'est pas toi tu vois
avec une maquette et une publité
donc la presse qui se qui se fabrique et
ce modèle économique il existe depuis
longtemps je je j'ai pas de sujet mais
il faut simplement être très vigilant la
presse qui se fabrique au moyen de de de
de financement publicitaire est une est
une est une presse qu'on doit lire avec
une attention plus et un recul un peu
plus un peu plus accru par exemple sur
Médiapart ou bacchich à l'époque ou sur
les jours ou AR sur image
bah h bon
euh c'est c'est c'est oui oui oui rest
sur image oui quand tu n'as pas
d'annonceur on est sur on est sur
quelque chose de de plus direct quoi la
courroie de transmission entre la
fabrication du produit et la manière
dont l'information te parvient et plus
courte deux dernières
questions déjà la première est-ce que tu
as des questions nous poser la dernière
laisse un conseil aux jeunes générations
euh
oui j'ai une question à te poser c'est
euh allez-vous nous inviter tous les de
mois comme on est en train de le faire
là parce que ça il faut que je
j'organise mon mon agenda là c'est
c'était exceptionnel là là déjà on avait
envie de te revoir parce que euh on ait
fait une bonne interview et on avait
bien discuté
et on peut se voir dans le privé mais la
communauté nous a réclamé c'était une
question pour rire en vrai ouais non non
les questions que j'ai à te poser tu
sais très bien quelles sont les les
questions que j'ai à te poser elles sont
évidemment hor cam et je ne vais pas
m'en priver dans quelques minutes là PL
pour faire avancer les sujets qui nous
tiennent d' à cœur euh les jeunes
générations bah les jeunes générations
voilà ça y est tu tu me fous dans la
dans la position du du gars qui doit
donner des conseils aux jeunes
générations c'est prière fois que ça
m'arrive je te merci pas pour ça
euh oui ben écoute moi j'ai j'ai envie
de leur dire de ne pas voter en fait et
et de dire au effort pourquoi il ne il
ne participe pas à ça et et si le le
message n'est pas assez clair euh je je
pense qu'il y a un conseil qui tient au
soulèvement
euh parce qu'on on doit mettre un terme
à ce qui est en train de se passer en
terme de de ma mise de la finance sur la
justice
et je vois tout de suite les tweets tu
vois dans cette espèce de d'écran mental
qui est le mien une sorte de machin un
hologramme qui est entre toi et moi les
tweets de ah le complot la théorie du
complot et cetera non non on vous parle
de fait en fait on vous parle de fait et
il y a un super programme à mettre en
œuvre et auquel les gens qui qui nous
regardent et notamment les jeunes
puisque c'est à eux que tu me demandes
de m'adresser de réfléchir c'est il est
tout simple et totalement
révolutionnaire puisque ça n'a jamais
été fait application de la loi aux
banques application de la loi aux po
nos lois sont bien en vrai je t'assure
que nos lois sont bien dire je les manie
au quotidien c'est mon boulot tu vois
elles sont très bien quand elles sont
appliquées à tout le monde et ça c'est
la définition d'une démocratie et quand
ça ça sera fait on pourra tous aller
voter tranquillement en attendant je
pense qu'il faut faire la grève du vote
David Koubi merci merci
[Musique]
sky